all right Samantha Samantha where you
from originally where'd you grow up
I was biggest and tell me what your
family you grew up with both your
parents um I did not I grew up on the
streets since I was 12
really yeah what happened at home that
you ended up on the street it was my
best friend at the time this girl she
her boyfriend came over and we he ended
up doing mess with us I was young and so
I ran away when I did it that night with
someone then your parents who you
staying with mom or dad um I was then
there was stay with my grandmother and
my mom and they let you go yeah yeah
they did report me missing a lot run
away as a runaway okay a lot so you
buried since since 12 yeah Wow yeah and
what you've been doing
how do you survive how do you support
yourself um back then I used to steal
cars with my boyfriend we were together
for like eight years maybe that he
wheezed to go to steal cars and stuff so
but then I turned 19 and I was in Salt
Lake and I started escorting I done left
Vegas to start which is kind of money
Salt Lake City escorting
tell me about that um it's actually good
the guys out there are very uh you know
they are awesome they support you that's
nice we're drugs a part of your picture
a part of the fiction yes since I was 12
yeah I've been on drugs since then with
drugs have been your go to UM meth and
heroin or pills I mean it's all the same
really so they were using today um Matt
I like today but I would love to owners
I mean I just don't want to get into
that lifestyle again where do you sleep
breathing um I live down in LA down 54th
so yeah every day yes
yeah I think goodness could you be on
the street I got a tent or yeah I
recently yeah which sucks but I stopped
working and escorting a few years ago so
money's
good how do you support yourself now I'm
just I was dancing but I don't do enough
of it so so dancing a district what huh
and what why do you get why you did not
continue with that why don't know I'm
still I mean I still want to I just not
being mobile and trying to figure I was
going into a program well that's why I'm
going a program though you're yeah okay
I was just in I was just at one in
Pacoima but yeah I did 45 days there
have you done programs before only once
how'd that go it was great
I got sober like eight years ago though
what gets you to relapse um people or my
emotions you know like where I'm at
people places and things they say where
it is were there any childhood events
that kind of like set you on this path
you think or why do you think you're in
this situation well because this is what
life don't mean but I'm just wondering
if there's anything and like in your
childhood that maybe kind of set this up
um I don't know probably I've had a bad
childhood I don't like talking about it
I don't like thinking about it so I just
try not to yeah drugs are a good way of
numbing yourself right yeah yeah it's
sad been talking about is a good way of
like fixing it
anything's alright oh yeah I talked
about it I don't know what they're
talking about
I mean was there any abuse yeah I was
abused by my mom she's to beat me she
hated me gosh I think it's just cuz she
was jealous I don't know she never hit
my brothers so that was only you only me
yeah now she'd never hit them she loved
them
you got the yeah the short end of a big
stick and was there ever any sexual
abuse yeah when I was six I lost my
virginity - it was bad - who - my
stepdads best friend used to take me to
baseball games mmm oh yeah for like a
year and a half he was like showing me
how to be how to be a lover and he
showed me how to kiss
and you showed me how it was crazy and
then he would come over to the house
where my dad was making dinner and he
would sit in front of my cousin's I feel
bad now cuz I didn't ever think about it
but I wonder if he missed he had to
probably be molesting my cousin's at
that point because he would have me kiss
him and show them what I did or what we
did have what we learned for kissing
both now I can't stand saliva because of
that [ __ ]
he had the wettest mouth so gross it's
weird because he would come is my
stepdads best friend right and he would
come and take me to games to baseball
games supposedly but we you know we
would go to his trailer and he would
like teach me how to be uh how to kit
how to kiss he taught that's how I'm
okay i started humping that's all or it
but i started humping everything because
of him because he talked like he did
something he showed me that when i like
pushed it or whatever that i would come
so i've been coming since i have six
like all the time I've even been
everything that's embarrassing
funny but anyway so he used to take me
to his trailer and yeah I used to do it
in school it was funny in fourth grade I
would just stand on the edge of my desk
I'd just do it in the middle of class
about everyone in there I would come all
the time I'm serious
but anyways yeah he's he violated my
eighth anals so it's [ __ ] that's
awful and it kind of six after he did
that I hid behind the couch after that I
was like I have to use the bathroom and
I hid and I and he found me back there
he didn't molest me anymore after that
but I never got caught nobody uh uh you
know no yeah and he was a teacher to me
you know yeah I used the teacher to be
one of the best thing um high school
actually yeah I mean you know he's
alright but not really you
well you know I was just brought brought
up a certain way if that's what they
wanted me to do and then that's what
they got did your parents ever find out
about this I don't know I told I never
told anybody till I was 18 and then my
grandma tried to switch it around on my
stepdad and make him look bad which was
awful I was she used me that way for
because he was a great dad
he's a great guy but his friends were
trouble no no my stepdad god no no oh
all right oh well I guess you're ready
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] he might even get guy
who his friends are now I know it's
awful looks pretty gross so I ain't
never told anybody because I don't want
to ruin anybody's lives
I do you think drugs are just a way of
kind of numbing that yeah but also
because I just like getting high now you
know like it's just like it's just
something I've learned you you know
you're like past the time I like to kick
it and you like it ah I was wrong dad
you know so I don't know dude do you see
yourself getting off drugs well I'm
going - I'm gonna go program I was
supposed to already be there honestly I
just got my bottom sheets fixed finally
God oh really yeah it was awful and then
it took like a year so what
sorry this is all theirs so embarrassed
was it crystal method let me show you my
ID it is horrifying I mean the big zit
every time I'm gonna pull it out I'm
super embarrassed oh [ __ ] sorry already
know it's so bad it's really bad
all right yeah you can check it out if
you have kids of your own no I don't I
wish I do not though hmm is that
something you gonna foresee happening
one day I would love to but I'm getting
older so I don't know we want to bring
kids into this world by the way though
it's not very good here mm-hmm
do you want to be a little more stable
before you start doing it oh for sure
yeah I would want to give you create a
good life not a shitty one do you saw
gotta be here your
nope they're all Dale or off selling
people out probably and you have a
boyfriend like that the year um not
right now kind of I'm seeing someone
okay kind of but he's been getting real
shitty so I'm not okay with that you
know it's like are you crazy
real hard yeah something that I'm just
pains in the asses yes
all right Samantha well thank you so
much for coming in and talking to me and
sure I'm good luck with your program yay
you